[Music]
jamaica
blue velvet
[Music]
uh
you're a great mom i don't know i'm fine
with trevor
but with phoebe she really keeps me on
the outside
that's normal she's an awkward nerdy kid
[Music]
maybe a new home can be an opportunity
to start fresh
i just wish you'd get into some trouble
there's still time
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway we're completely broke
and our grandfather left us this creepy
old farmhouse in the middle of nowhere
your father wasn't much of a homemaker
he could hardly keep the power on
you're saying he left us nothing well i
wouldn't say nothing
[Music]
you went with station wagon it's the
only one that had an engine
what is happening here somehow
a town with no fault lines is shaking on
a daily basis
maybe it's the apocalypse
egon came out here for a reason are you
troubled by strange noises in the middle
of the night
you experience feelings of dread in your
basement or attic
have you or any of your family ever seen
a spook inspector or ghost
[Music]
oh my god
you guys hear that something's coming
all city it's like the walking dead
go
we're closed
[Music]
what are you doing here in summerville
anyway honestly
my mom won't say it but we're completely
broke
and the only thing that's left in our
name is this creepy old farmhouse our
grandfather left us in the middle of
nowhere
why'd you bring me up here entertainment
value
what is that i don't know
somehow a town that isn't anywhere near
a tectonic plate
that has no fault lines no fracking no
loud music even
is shaking on a daily basis
hey remember that one summer we died on
our table
i found this in my living room killer
replica
a replica of what a ghost trap
there hasn't been a ghost sighting in 30
years
new york in the 80s it's like the
walking dead
your dad never mentioned this to you
it's just my mom
[Music]
my grandfather died my mom says we're
just here to pick through the rub love's
[Music]
life
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it faith
call it lock
[Music]
call it karma
[Music]
i believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darling
it has a gunner seat
[Music]
i'm ivan reitman director of
ghostbusters and ghostbusters too
better known as dad and i'm his son
jason reitman director of ghostbusters
afterlife
the ghostbusters 84 set is the first set
i can remember
as a kid it was just simply magical he
was there with his mom
my wife and uh they in fact
they actually used it in this in one
moment in the film when
we got cut out of the original
ghostbusters that's what he's getting at
they got scared after the first take
jason wouldn't do a second take
ghostbusters afterlife is a movie about
a family that's being made by a family
and it is much about the passing of
torch metaphorically and the passing of
a proton pack
it was very emotional to see that uh
story living again after so many years
through my son i grew up
as a fan i had a flight suit i had the
t-shirt i had the hat
now at this age i find myself trying to
understand who my father is
and who he was when he made this film
you know i am now the age that my father
was when he made the original
ghostbusters movie and i'm trying to
understand him
in the same way that phoebe and callie
are trying to understand where they came
from
while making the movie my father's
presence was felt
most like this inches away watching the
monitor
imagine yourself in your workplace and
your parents
are sitting right next to you watching
you take every phone call
watching you present any idea chiming in
often
[Music]
it was probably more fun for me than for
jason
there was a moment when we were shooting
with three cameras a scene with
five or six actors and i found myself
on set sitting next to one of the
cameras watching one actor in particular
who i wanted a performance from
and after the take was done i ran back
to monitor to review the other cameras
and my father looked at me and just said
you got it i went okay
and i nodded and we moved on which is
not an experience i could have ever
happened or probably will ever happen on
any other movie
jason had a remarkable responsibility
having to deal with
his father on the set and also the
history and iconography of
35 years of audiences all over the world
getting to know this movie and he took
it on which i thought was a great thing
to do
my father and i are extraordinarily
close it was a joyful experience
just to be there it was the great
bonding experience of my life with the
director that i admire most
my father
phone's probably mine dad i'm in the
like i i'm trying
to do the ep
back to one guys
[Music]
[Music]
you